different SEPTA types are required for  different types of applications PTFE is  the most inert and has excellent  chemical resistance but has poor  resealability making it best for single  injection only PTFE silicone means it  has PTFE resistance until it's punctured  when it's punctured the silicone layer  is exposed and able to react with the  analyte it has excellent resealing  capabilities and has excellent chemical  resistance until punctured perfect for  applications that can handle multiple  injections with moderate resistance now  pre-slit PTFE silicone is perfect for  use with auto Samplers and also helps  reduce coring meaning a piece of rubber  breaking off due to repeated syringe  insertion and helps prevent vacuuming  from inside the vial it can also handle  multiple injections and has excellent  chemical resistance until punctured